to present the animation live-action
short films hey this is the one time I
get to do this you know we have a woman
who went from stand-up comedy to motion
picture starter now few women have done
this
only one other comes to mind in any case
this lady was Madonna's friend at a
league of their own
meg Ryan's friend and Sleepless in
Seattle and after this gracious
introduction she better be my friend too
the star of the new Broadway production
of grease miss Rosie O'Donnell
I look at me I'm on the Academy Awards
can you believe it I got the dress I got
the jewels I got the breasts and they
all have to be back by midnight but this
is the tops the apex the big Oh Oscar
night and I'm a part of it and to be
asked to give out the awards for Best
Actor Best Actress and Best Picture was
really too much to hope for
turns out it was but I'm perfectly
delighted to be handing out statuettes
in two great categories animated short
films and live-action short films first
a word about animation yabba-dabba-doo
you've been hearing how many people
behind the camera it takes to make a
film well it takes a heck of a lot more
to make a film without people an
animated film now to honor those
animated filmmakers who have made a
great impression this year here are the
nominees for best animated short film
line scape by Steven Palmer the mighty
river by Frederick back and who baptise
ol small talk by Bob Godfrey and Kevin
Baldwin the village by Mark Baker the
wrong trousers by Nick Park and the
Oscar goes to the wrong trousers
Nicholas Park
thank you don't believe it I just like
to thank company directors Thank You
Peter Lord David's Broxton and all the
team Aardman Animations in Bristol
England a particularly Steve box active
Peter Salas and everybody at the BBC and
I'd like to thank the Academy for still
supporting the short film category as
many direct and many directors here
started by making short films so thanks
for giving us a chance bye-bye
I now have the pleasure of announcing
the nominees in the category live-action
short films and they are black rider
Schwarz for her
Pepe Dan quark
down on the waterfront Stacy title and
jonathan penner the dutch master susan
Seidelman and jonathan Brett partners
Peter Weller and Jan assume Emma the
screw lovey's DDA flem oh and the Oscar
goes to black writer Schwarz for her
Wow
I needn't dare to dream about that now
it's true I prepared a speech a short
film have to be a short speech I vote
for you oh no this was my lead actor
pilote long is over there and the
Academy asked us to be brief brief brief
so thank you